Angefangen hat alles Anfang März
in der Bahn.
Da hat Victoria gemerkt,
dass sich etwas verändert hat:
skeptische Blicke von Fremden,
Fahrgäste, die aufstehen
und in ein anderes Abteil gehen.
Ich hab zuerst gedacht,
dass ich mir das einbilde,
hab aber dann wirklich beobachtet,
dass die Leute mir zuerst
ins Gesicht geguckt haben
und sich dann weggesetzt haben.
Und [ich] bin dann
drei Personen hinterhergelaufen,
um sicherzugehen, ob die nicht
vielleicht ausgestiegen sind.
Die Personen haben sich aber in einen
anderen Vierer oder ins Fahrradabteil gesetzt.
Victoria Kure-Wu ist Deutsche.
Ihre Eltern kamen schon lange
vor ihrer Geburt nach Deutschland.
Vorurteile wegen ihres Aussehens
kennt sie bereits.
Als nach dem Corona-Ausbruch in China
auch in Deutschland erste Fälle auftreten,
häufen sich jedoch die Vorkommnisse.
Mitten im Herzen des liberalen Berlins
schlägt ihr offener Hass entgegen:
Ein Mann ruft ihr zu, man solle sie
mit Desinfektionsmittel einsprühen.
Ich hab das Gefühl,
seitdem gehe ich geduckter
oder so ein bisschen kleiner
durch die Straße
und hab Angst vor Anfeindungen.
Ich muss auch echt zugeben, dass,
wenn mehrere Leute vor ’ner Bar
irgendwie stehen,
dass ich manchmal die Straßenseite wechsle.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
seit dem Homeoffice bin ich froh,
dass ich nicht mehr auf die Straße gehe,
weil ich keine Lust hab mehr,
angefeindet zu werden.
Und [ich] hab auch das Gefühl, dass ich
von vielen Leuten, obwohl ich in Berlin lebe,
einfach nicht als Deutsche
wahrgenommen werde.
Victoria suchte das Gespräch.
Doch viele ihrer deutschen Freunde
wiegelten ab.
Sie fühlte sich mit ihrem Problem
nicht ernst genommen.
Über Facebook hat sie daher Kontakt
zu anderen Betroffenen
in ganz Deutschland aufgebaut.
Seit Beginn der Pandemie werden hier
fast täglich neue Anfeindungen
gegen Menschen
mit asiatischem Aussehen gemeldet.
Popo Fan ist Chinese und
lebt wie Victoria in Berlin.
Auch er wurde bereits mehrfach
in der U-Bahn rassistisch beleidigt
und hat die Übergriffe
mit dem Telefon gefilmt.
Ein Freund sagte zu mir:
„Das solltest du unbedingt melden!“
Ich setze zwar wenig Hoffnung in die Polizei,
aber ich möchte den Leuten zeigen:
Ich habe diese Beweise und
lasse mich nicht zum Schweigen bringen.
Sich mit anderen Betroffenen auszutauschen
– das hat Victoria Kure-Wu
am meisten geholfen.
Deswegen arbeitet sie
momentan an einer Website,
die Vernetzungs- und Hilfsangebote
für Betroffene bündelt.
Das ist, glaube ich, wichtig,
dass Leute in Zeiten von Social Distancing
sich vernetzen können,
ihre Erfahrungen sichtbar machen können
und Leute davon lesen können.
Rassismus wird es in Deutschland vermutlich
auch nach der Corona-Krise geben,
sagt Victoria Kure-Wu.
Doch dass die Opfer sich nicht mehr
verloren fühlen müssen –
dazu möchte sie beitragen.